hi there Steve again continuing my
Korean challenge cleaned up after dinner
I'm going to go off and do some Korean
reading on link but I just had a thought
that I wanted to share with you somebody
came on my channel here and said and I
get this from time to time uh you know
what's the point of being intermediate
at best in so many languages you're
better off to be really good at a few
you know why do you pretend you're
fluent when you're not and and words of
that effect and I've had people come on
before you know your chinese is really
quite mediocre and stuff so in praise of
mediocrity I think it's great to be
intermediate in a language i think it's
great to be mediocre in a language
because we learn languages for ourselves
so if i can communicate if i can read
and listen to things that interest me
and I can communicate with people i'm
happy i think was cattle of the famous
Hungarian polyglot of the 20th century
who said language is the only thing
worth knowing poorly or something to
that effect so I think people should
just accept whatever they achieve be
happy for it be happy for what they're
able to do enjoy every moment they spend
with a language which I do I you know
and sometimes I have to remind myself
you know I'm working through my career
and I don't think I'm making progress
but I'm enjoying it I'm learning about
stuff so mediocrity is good it's good
because you have to enjoy every moment
that you're spending with the language
not to mention the fact that to be
intermediate in a language he's pretty
good and particularly if it's based on
good comprehension which I consider to
be the most important thing if you get
more opportunity to speak you lend or
speaking better so there you have no I
was asked by someone I can't remember
who who said that their girlfriend is
Chinese and is struggling to learn
English and could I say a few words of
encouragement to her in Chinese so I'll
follow this up with a another video
where I'll say more or less the same
thing in Chinese to encourage this
learner
in China and I might you know have a few
more things took but i'm not going to
provide a translation or a transcript
sorry and now you have it in praise of
mediocrity you know celebrate what
you're able to do enjoy it and don't
worry if you put it enough time you will
improve guaranteed especially if you
enjoy it and in order to enjoy it pat
yourself on the back of your now and
again okay bye for now jajaja washer
Steve Kaufman a yo Ian yo come what is a
YouTube channel the entire Chicago team
o.k Todd upon yo yo yo man mmm yes
roaming Ishod traffic udita she she she
seeing me my dear girl a web browser
maker on camera tada tioga ponyo a
center tab anupam yo Suh Joon were a
hundred haz in la Tasha to the melting
book yo dr CA chillin nahmad tattoo odd
or run difficult idea so you were Santa
you doin di-dong organs are young you
enjoy the day georgia wallah yo Dorian
you're gonna feel a peeping walk show
the hard or what John danisha and John
dibujar quadrature put Samia to her eben
delegate reading and butcher haha what
the John jaha take the devil feet on me
oh I just want your mail lingsha give me
some not you mean it was sure she will
it's easy well Nadia one can is here we
can sing to the donkey a see Usher Hall
oh ya crib or but what easily are
actually and Torah cry yo soy yo sure
haha bodega her desire Honda Tahiti
Zhong ke ke chali sorry woman-to-woman
dulha bhai otro dia shoot you sure May
yes young Papa daughter
yo lodge near lurch in Ohio kanda myojin
book near shanxi initial yonder [ __ ]
jay-z buffa sure your yonder near away
shared it again Sri Sri yonder certainly
lady answer to me on Arsenio she awoke
and inquiry but again she died Shangri
La Liga he gave me the table idea when
man man do what the ocho de in shaping
done is no water at all watching the job
done when you mean hon ja ja doma can do
know koo ja-cheol who's away your
relative in what was away to yacht
riyadh shi shi yao shang ke ke your
shyness in the Georgia young yaya a
tourist region rajnagar surgeon we are
aware not sure mmm huzzah 20 large iron
a shirt William media room initially
llega English we are searching boy Osama
tempo eating a sham bhava yo la tarea
she'll CEO is narrow your sword 20
lighter your Easter check your either
dig surg baba ha yo chill don't hang on
yuusha mayo / need a guitar or continue
warming the tonnage couldn't inc co
issue hey she away to really see a zoo
go that zuko that sir ji tian her again
and GG the title jo kiya sandra parker
hallelujah holla iono me Jagran Juanita
english Reverend George I bandar puchong
ye Shiwen Panama cow Moos away needles
Reba ya que haya teacher huh what Tom
light for the title ok just yet yeah